6 25 on your monday morning how about uh  wondering about those giant video  screens near busy roads got an email  from terry who writes with driver  distraction being one of the leading  causes of crashes does it really make  sense to put up a 27 600 square foot  video screen on the side of a legion  stadium for folks driving on the freeway  to watch football what could possibly go  wrong excellent question terry someone  also wondered about the exterior resorts  world playing giant videos next to the  strip now i've not talked to either  allegiant or resorts world and i'm  curious to hear your thoughts uh the  address coming right up in the meantime  please buckle up drive carefully and put  down that phone  if there's something driving you crazy  or you want to respond the email address  traffic 8 8newsnow.com